mystic abuse at Gao allegations whether
against a top White House official for
causing a new shake-up at the White
House this morning
staff secretary Rob Porter gatekeeper to
the Oval Office is on his way out after
his two ex-wives claimed that he abused
them one of them says he punched her in
the face Rob Porter calls the charges
false and outrageous he could leave as
early as today Julianna Goldman is at
the White House Juliana good morning
good morning well the role of staff
secretary is one of the most important
jobs in the White House they oversee
every piece of paper that lands on the
President's desk from articles to
classified briefing materials he is
going to be leaving the White House
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders said presidential aide Rob
Porter personally decided to resign
Porter's first wife Cobie Holderness
shared photos with the intercept website
showing what her face looked like after
he allegedly punched her while on
vacation in a statement Porter said
these outrageous allegations are simply
false but admitted he had taken the
photos his second wife Jennifer
Willoughby detailed the abuse with the
Washington Post within a matter of a
couple of weeks after being married I
was aware of his temper he came and
grabbed me by the shoulders here and and
pulled me out of a shower in a range
initially the administration came to
Porter's defense Sanders described him
as having exemplary character chief of
staff John Kelly said Porter was a man
of integrity but Kelly later amended his
statement to say he was shocked by the
new allegations Willoughby told FBI
investigators in January of 2017 about
what she says was his abusive past the
FBI shared those allegations with the
White House ten months later I told them
all of the details of my marriage
including verbal and emotional abuse
they were also made aware of the
of order that I signed it sources tell
CBS News Porter's full security
clearance was then delayed it's not
clear if he ever received full clearance
as staff secretary Porter would vet
every single document before it got to
the President's desk including
classified materials I would be
surprised if you could do it without
full security clearance Katherine Dunn
tempest studies the presidency for the
Brookings Institution the staff
secretary is sort of what makes the
wheels turn every single day CBS News
has also learned that Porter is dating
White House communications director hope
Hicks and she was one of the staffers
involved in drafting the earlier
statements defending Porter Giuliana
chief of staff Kelly said these were new
allegations but they weren't the FBI had
given this information to the White
House so how did the White House handle
it did they look into them or did they
look for a workaround to his security
clearance questions John that's right I
mean as you just said the White House
learned about these allegations in
November we know that in December Porter
was considering leaving but he didn't
and in fact his role was recently
expanded dealing with more policy issues
even helping to draft the State of the
Union and all of this with the full
support of the White House chief of
staff Julianna thanks